have you guys been watching any good
Korean soap operas I'm pretty deep into
he Jung Cinderella girl although I
definitely fast forward to the young T
story Alliance do you think I'd like
that or is it important to have an Asian
fetish uh I think you're going to need
to have an Asian fetish yeah it'll be
upsetting if you don't got to catch a
plane oh hey Gabe I'm sorry we we didn't
get you a cake or anything we're going
to miss you oh well I'm still the
corporately as on to the branch you are
not leaving not giving me a hug
okay you know what you don't need to
make that sound I'm sorry you were just
a lot bonier than I thought you were
going to be there are plenty of people
who love touching me I'm a terrific
hugger I've been with a bunch of girls
where that's basically all they want to
do everyone please
relax I think you're going to like this
surprise
guest happy birthday to gab oh get out
Skeleton
Man hey I need you to get the paper we
rolling on a new workplace relationship
for you yes for Gabe who are you seeing
that's great whom I'm seeing is Val from
down in the warehouse I'm not
technically seeing her but uh I've seen
her with the eyes and uh there was ATT
Traction in at least One Direction
so you know I don't have to do paperwork
unless you're actually dating okay well
once the starts it's going to be moving
fast it's going to be hot and heavy and
I don't want a bunch of bureaucratic red
tape wrapped around my jock you know
but I mean have you talked to her yeah
we had a whole conversation about
Mondays do you know her last name yet
Toby I'm going to tell you her last name
tomorrow because she's going to be
screaming it tonight she's going to be
screaming her own last name hey watch
it good luck gab I need girl
talk did someone say girl
talk sometimes I wonder if I have
ovaries in my scrotum because I am great
at girl
talk yes I am anxious to get out of work
but let me be clear it's not to
celebrate St Patrick's Day it's so I can
protest St Patrick's Day over we not all
my damn bags home I'm carrying nothing
but my sabled gloves I've had it with
Homeland Security and I want you to put
all those tracking numbers in my
Blackberry how late are we going to work
tonight you never know at Joe sometimes
we're here till midnight sometimes she
doesn't show up for 3 days why does she
do that why does she just tell you what
your schedule is yeah that would be
awesome I could get a girlfriend
wouldn't have to go to Amsterdam seven
times a year but uh I'm young right I
will date when I'm
dead stay away from Aaron hey I'm your
boss why don't you uh stay away from me
I'm going to stand where I want okay you
don't want to get on my bad side I've
seen some horrible things I over 200
horror movies okay that's so weird just
go away no you go
[Music]
away ke you I need to talk to you you
can't be in here this is a lady's B Aon
Aon I respect your privacy but I will
follow you in here every time you go if
that's what it takes he not cool
man I really think you should leave
someday you are going to tell our
grandchildren about how their
grandfather won you back in a women's
room can we talk about this later I have
to go okay just read the letter under
your windshield wiper okay it explains
everything okay do you want Gabe well
Gabe swee eron I'm thring the Halloween
party and I just want to amp it up a
little I think it could use some extra
Pizzazz okay where does gate factor in
remember that Halloween party you took
me to once the one where I I started
crying as soon as I walked in and I
didn't stop crying yes Lars and Tacos
okay well let's say that I wanted this
party to be a tiny tiny bit like that
one
just more adult more more scary and sexy
I would make this sexier than you could
ever imagine no just scary if we wanted
ideas for scary
stuff okay everybody be
prepared to be
scared okay
[Music]
okay the cinema of the unsettling is a
growing film movement the most
well-known film in the genre is an hour
long shot of a squirrel with
diarrhea
[Music]
okay
okay is that my grandmother what's the
story it is no story yeah it seems like
there isn't a narrative maybe the
filmmaker realized that even narrative
is
[Music]
comforting what the hell is going on
here you don't know what it is like to
love a woman and have love you back it
is a feeling that cannot and will not
and frankly cannot be contained no one
is a bigger fan of sexual touching than
me but with you two it's reaching the
level of a complex I can think of three
explanations one you're taking MDMA
street name ecstasy I've done it and I
know the feeling no I I don't think so
number two you're desperately trying to
fit in a whole relationship before toi
comes back from jury duty and Holly has
to go back to
nasua or three you know you're at an age
where your sexual climaxes aren't as
powerful so you need to overcompensate
with foreplay tapoo
Behavior yes it was that it's that one
yes number three In fairness Daryl did
tell me that joke so I feel like I say
it Daryl's funny I know right hey Andy
yeah um can I talk to you a second about
these client memos sure
what's going
on are you still in love with Aaron what
because I am I need to get her back I
can't be alone
anymore Andy do you like being alone
with me right now no this is horri no I
don't like being alone with me either
okay I have to get her in back are you
you still going to date her we're just
friends okay do you promise
that yeah fine I promise we'll never
date again can we go outside now no just
give me a second I don't want anyone to
know I've been
crying
Gabe what we should break
up what I'm not attracted to
you I just I cringe when you talk I have
to be
honest right right
Pam thank you for hearing
me okay well this is embarrassing
um obviously really angry at earn it
comes that quarter life crisis
everyone's talking
about all right I'm I'm going to
go freaking need a favor well then you
have to call me by my name Gabriel Susan
Lewis I wish my gym didn't allow full
nudity in the locker room okay some of
these old guys walking around naked
feels almost passive aggressive but I
deal with it because it's policy see
what I mean no nudity makes me
uncomfortable okay my gym allows it I
wish they didn't but it's policy so I
respect it and I just keep a low you
know Look Away think about your
commission cap
as a naked old man in a gym like
room it seems Andy is the only one with
this problem fascinating fascinating I
don't really see what the problem is
Aaron doesn't even like sex remember you
said it feels like getting tackled by a
skeleton feel how fat my buttocks are
yeah it's crazy touch it it's like a
warm pumpkin so Andy just called you up
out of the blue
yeah you told me you two broke up yeah
you must be pretty
horny I still wear aon's button BS
around the condo sometimes so it feels
to me like we're still in a relationship
G A lot of the
time Gabe did Aaron ever tell you that
she loves you no no no no no no no no no
no she wouldn't even let me say it it
was adorable she'd plug her ears and
scream her heart out can you stop
talking because every word out of your
mouth is like the squawk of an ugly
pelican
I got a tattoo for you I didn't ask you
to get that Nike Swoosh nobody did you
did that for you just do
it you were the it that I was just doing
so you're dating a secretary now moving
up in the world Pete she's nice to me
how's that PE degree coming that's what
he wanted to be his dream in college was
to be a gym teacher well guess what he
could still be a gym teacher in fact we
could all still be gym teachers so let's
I technically cannot I don't have the
lung capacity to blow a whistle
God what kind of music are you into
Peter uh I like all kinds of music Gabe
really all kinds so she likees songs of
hate written by the white Knights of the
Klux Clan Erin are you even hearing this
he didn't even say that he's not a very
sophisticated man I mean he can't use
chopsticks so do I need to say anything
else Aaron I've been to Japan I know how
to use chopsticks so well come back one
night keep I don't
night